Russian State media is reporting that
President Putin has visited the
Ukrainian city of mariopol in what's
believed to be his first visit to
Russian occupied territories of the Don
bass region of Ukraine since the War
Began this footage is said to show the
president driving around the streets of
Mario Paul the port city that Russian
forces captured in the early stages of
the invasion after Fierce fighting the
city is now said to be largely destroyed
though Russia has been rebuilding parts
of it to try to raise its Ukrainian
Heritage
State media in Russia have also released
this footage in which it says uh Putin
has visited the city's Philharmonic
theater the same Hall that was allegedly
used by Russia to hold prisoners of War
during sham trials that were held there
let's bring in our chief correspondent
shoot Ramsey who's joining us now from
Ukraine this morning good morning to you
Stuart good to have you with us so what
do you make of the fact that we've now
seen Putin allegedly popping up in
maripo
yeah I it is definitely symbolic you
know this came in the week that he was
indicted by the ICC for illegal
trafficking of children to all intents
and purposes and he's been to Crimea to
celebrate the ninth anniversary of its
takeover of Crimea and of course his
first stop was to go and see a load of
children and now he we understand he
took a helicopter to mariopol and as you
said been driving around talking to
people Mario Paul was is a significant
Place obviously it's extremely uh
important for the Russians and obviously
Ukraine wants to get it back there's
also the scene of some terrible fighting
and if we're talking about the ICC well
there's an awful lot of allegations of
war crimes against Putin and his forces
uh there as well
is where we're watching a lot of the
fighting taking place at the moment it's
actually gone for longer than Mary opple
but bachmanism very much smaller place
mariopol is a big city and really
significant and obviously as I say this
is very much a symbolic visit by the
president it is interesting he hasn't
really gone to the front lines president
zielinski goes quite often and that's to
boost morale for his troops but um uh
president
and the Russian president often doesn't
go and in this throughout this war he's
mainly been uh in Moscow we also
understood though that he's in Russian
territory was meeting some of his senior
commanders as well as I say this is
actually
um for the photographs and the cameras
it's to sort of show a message back home
that not only uh is is it business as
usual for the president but he can
actually go uh pretty much wherever he
wants and into Ukraine as well if you
take Crimea is obviously part of Ukraine
but this was right into the to the front
line areas uh if you like so it that's
what symbolism I suppose is all about
you say it's a show strength to those
back home but I mean you're in kieva I
wonder how because they'll see these
pictures I wonder how it will be
received there because of course Mario
Paul is firmly in the sights of of the
Ukrainian forces to eventually take back
oh yeah they absolutely determined
they'll take it back though it is going
to be a very difficult fight and
obviously this war is really grinding on
and all the indicators from um from both
sides particularly Russia who are
thinking of calling up more soldiers
that this really could go on for a very
long time indeed people will see it here
they will be irritated by it obviously
but there's nothing that President Putin
does that will surprise him anymore it's
the type of thing they will expect to
see I don't think it'll make much
difference than one way or the other you
know the last week or two that we've
been here I've talked to a lot of people
about sort of weariness of War Etc
because there's huge numbers of
Ukrainian soldiers being killed and been
to lots and lots of different funerals
but no you know that the country remains
United they hate the war but they are
determined to keep fighting and so
President Putin turning up in in
mariopol is not going to affect the
people of Ukraine in any shape or form
and they're certainly not going to take
it as anything other than a simple
symbol that he can go there for now uh
that all it will do is make them term to
make sure that he can't go there in the
future so you're right okay Stuart for
now and Keith appreciate your time thank
you